今日の
セカンドチャンネルの
動画は
なんと
なんとですね
今日はね
1人で焼き肉に来てるということで
任侠東海オンエア
てつや
はははは
うえーい
はい！こんにちわ
今、東海オンエア
話すとすごい難しいんですけど
なんて言えばいい？！
東海オンエア
僕ん家に遊びに来てるんですけど
彼らは僕としか会わないと思っていて
マホっちゃんの存在を知らないんすよ！
ま）そうっすよ
東海オンエアの車借りてここに来てて
東海オンエア
ま）これそうなんだ！
そう！
ま）へぇー
東海オンエアの2人はドンキに置き去りにしております
今からマホっちゃんを俺ん家に置いて
最近巨大バケツを買ったんっすよ
ま）あーそうなんだ
そん中にマホっちゃんが入って
あいつら2人が帰ってきたときに
マホっちゃんがバッって出てきて
ま）そういうことか！
マホっちゃんがくること自体知らないし
ま）そっか
まずマホっちゃんが来たら
やつらは間違えなく恐怖におびえるから
はははは
ほんとにyoutuberしか分かんないんですけど
ものすごいドッキリなんすよ！これ
じゃあ早速いってみましょう
ま）東海オンエアだけに
ま）ドッキリをするのもあれなので
ま）プチドッキリ、ちょっとしたドッキリをね
ま）やりたいと思います
ま）ちょっとこけてもらおうかな
ま）ちょー簡単なドッキリをやりたいと思います
ま）OK!
はじめて入るんか
どうぞ
し）失礼します
し）お邪魔します
て）見えたもーん
ざまぁみやがれ！
うわっ！
ま）うわーー
わっ！
（爆笑）
というわけで
大成功！！